so hi everyone and welcome to pydera
global 2021
um
so for your information this session is
recorded
um we're going to have a workshop given
by silviali which is called
bridging data and business power plant
output optimization based on electricity
market
price
sylvia will take question at some point
during the workshop i'll let her know
when she's uh happy to get questions
from from the crowd
the floor is yours
right thank you
so welcome everyone to a workshop
so this is the workshop for bridging
data and business so what we're actually
going to go through is how you can set
up for the best success going into any
sort of data science project around the
business context uh so we'll be also
surrounding this on a use case call for
power plant output optimizations uh so
we'll have the data science parts which
is predicting the power plant
productions uh and then we'll have a
kind of business market parts worth it
um which is using um
market prices
to make decisions on buy-in cells
so just a little bit of introduction for
myself i am a data scientist at integra
data analytics solutions i had a master
degree from ubc uh for the master of
data science and then just kind of just
continue on that path coming out on
working with integra on a lot of
different data science projects for our
clients specifically in the oil and gas
sectors uh and then now we are actually
part of now vertical um we had the
acquisitions uh not a long time ago so
that's that
uh so just a little bit of agenda uh
throughout the workshop today uh i'll be
taking questions um pretty much at every
single transition point so i'll be going
through a presentation here on machine
learning best practices um best
practices as in like when you're dealing
with in the business context not so much
of like the actual working of itself but
like inside of best practices to have
the best collaborations uh with your
business partners uh and then a short
introduction on our platform called the
dual hub that we have built for data
science uh and then in the transition of
this going into the actual use cases
themselves i would take some questions
and then but we'll go through the use
case on the jupyter notebook and also a
little bit of hands-on session how to
build a production grade dashboard on
superset uh and then after that also we
can take a more of a q a section as well
so just a little bit of introduction of
who we are uh so now vertical uh we are
a vertically aligned beta analytics
software and service company whose
outsole mission is actually taking a
combination of the most advanced
automation digital technology and with
any sort of deep vertical expertise that
we have
combining them to provide the invaluable
tools to our clients and customers to
make solutions faster and make better
data
data informative decisions through the
diagnostic and predictive and
prescriptive model that we can provide
and integra now we're part of the
non-vertical umbrella
as kind of the lead on the energy sector
so we had years of experience with
different consultant projects in the oil
and gas sectors
we have provided a lot of solutions that
help solve real world operational
challenges using data science and
machine learning solutions and now
because of code
we went in and built out a data science
platform that actually puts now the
power of data science into the hands of
our customers
so now going into part uh for machine
learning best practices with the
business um and how you can set over the
best success uh when you're looking uh
to do some data science projects with a
business partner
so we have come down to two very key
points um from our years of um doing
consulting projects and just
communicating with our clients two very
very important points that actually set
to us for success so the first point is
you always want to keep in mind of what
is most important
data science is called data science
because data is the most important part
of it um a lot of times people get
carried away with buzzwords like ai
machine learning deep learning um and
then they kind of do sites of what is
most important so we always want to make
our models and solution work best for
the data the ultimate goal is to get
insight out of the data but not the
other way around so the model really
only performs as good as the data you
give it so whenever we communicate that
across
so kind
always be prepared to make it clear to
them that you spending time and efforts
on the data itself is ultimately what's
going to give you um success down the
road so
be prepared
to allocate time to just do data
cleaning wrangling feature engineering
data transformation anything you name it
data
the second point of it is also very
important is know exactly what your
objective is
a lot of times
when you go into a client they have a
very big picture of what um the business
problem is and there's so many things
that they want to solve it is a very big
landscape that they want to try to
tackle but for you to get the best
success out of it is you actually want
to pinpoint exactly where the pain
points are um
you want to find a problem that
when solving it it helps them with a
pinpoint that's painful enough to
justify values in your solution but at
the same time best problem might
actually be a very simple data science
problem that you can actually
finish and give results to within a
couple a short frame of time
so just pinpointing a very small simple
but valuable problem and having that
it's like building a sand castle you
have that one cent and eventually you
can build the entire sand castle just
building on top of the small big small
problem and eventually maybe solving the
entire business problem that they have
so that was
um just two key oversights and now
in terms of setting yourself up for
success now you're in this business
partnership um we have
defined that four big sections um or
categories that we usually go in and
explore with our um subject matter
experts to ensure that we are
everyone is aligned with what the
objectives are and know where we're
going so first off the data you want to
know exactly what your data is you want
to communicate very closely at this
point with your subject matter experts
to make sure that you're in line uh with
what they understand about the data and
what you understand about the data and a
lot of times during this conversation
what you actually find out are gaps
inside the data and those gaps might
actually transform into the objective
itself
the second part of it is know the nature
of the problem once you have an idea of
what kind of problem you're tackling is
a classification problem it's a
clustering problem what is the key
metrics that is going to be
what you're using to measure the
performance of the model so this uh is
in terms of help the data scientists are
on that end to know where you're going
eventually in that model building
process
uh the third uh section that we have
here that i think sometimes people don't
put enough attention to is the ethical
implications so you actually want to
know exactly in every step of the
process from data collections to gate
data cleaning to model building and the
final presentation of your business
outcome or your predictions and results
what are the ethical implications in
every single step or that you want to
make sure that you're not stepping into
any problems
with
ethical implications and concerns here
the last part um envisioning the final
product very often just the list of
numbers that you get from a prediction
model that's not your final result that
you're going to present to them they're
looking for something like a dashboard
or a report um the model that you're
building actually is not going to be run
on a jupyter notebook or a local script
it's going to be somewhere up deployed
in the cloud or on the on-premise um
software so you want to know exactly
where your model is going and where your
result is going and in terms of that
sometimes those um knowing that actually
plays a part into when you're deciding
what models you want to build if
computation is going to be a bottleneck
maybe deep learning is not a good idea
so
having to know that every single these
four sections
knowing exactly where you're going to
set out your for success and you're
actually in night your expenses partner
knows where you're going and
just avoids a lot of conclusions and
assumptions down the road
now the iterative process itself in
terms of building that data science
models or when you're doing any sort of
machine learning projects um i guess the
data scientists we know the steps we
know how to go through it but this is
kind of the way that we have organized
it in a way so we can communicate
efficiently with our business partner so
that they know exactly where we are um
so with the exploration stage this is
the data exploration you're defining the
objectives you're doing your exploratory
analysis you're communicating with
subject matter experts um so then
actually what you find out about the
data might actually
defines your objective shifted or even
like change the directions completely so
in this exploration stage you're
defining that objective you're
pinpointing the um problem exactly
according to how the data is looking
like then we go into the model building
process which is another little
iterative process of itself so this is
where i guess the data scientists the
data analyst comes in we work on the
data we transform the data do feature
engineering we do the model
optimizations to know model
hyperparameter tuning and maybe go
through a few models go through a few um
sets of transformation pipelines and
eventually come up with the best model
that we got um given the time frame that
we have
and then once you have that model with
uh the minimal fiber product or the mvp
then like you can start taking that
model to the model growth phase so this
is the part where you might actually
launch up the model into a bit of a
production environment where you can
actually start seeing how the model
performs in real life with real-time
data coming in and eventually take those
new data retrain your model make a model
better and deploy again so there's a
little iterative process in itself and
very often the model growth phase is
actually work gets the most excitement
um that's also the extreme attraction
that comes in with ai and machine
learning is because the model can grow
it's not like a static model that just
stays there in time and
just doesn't evolve um with the weight
changes
so that was just a very quick uh
starting stage on like some of the
things that we have learned from past
experience working with our business
partner and in terms of um
building data science projects um so
throughout our time on here um when
covert hits uh we have a little bit of
data science platform internally we
decide to bring it out with a ui so it's
available um to the public
so just a little bit on digital hub uh
this is the data science platform that
we have built uh what we were
noticing is that there was a bit of a
lag between a data science development
and business intelligence so that we
have built out the platform that hosts
the most advanced open source
development visualization and learning
applications in the cloud environment
and then the overall aim of this is that
everything is pre-configured integrated
and ready to be used so then you can
spend less time on setting things up and
configuring and more time targeting and
working on the problem itself so we have
also wanted to to be a friendly
collaborative environment so there's a
lot of teamworking kind of capabilities
are integrated to different parts of the
platform on here and we're very three
main
features that we have so one is out of
the box everything is pre-configured and
ready to use cost effective because
you're able to actually manage all of
these applications on your dashboard
your business intelligent dashboards um
your jupyter lab development
environments you can choose to start and
stop those run times so manage your cost
efficiency that way
and we also have some expert notebooks
and template notebooks inside the
algebra lab environments that helps
guide you along the process and do a
little bit of tutorial and just let you
know how to deal with a problem when you
get one
so just a little bit of overview uh i'll
be also scrolling onto the dashboard uh
the platform itself and show you a
little bit more uh in the later parts of
this um workshop when we get into the
use case but just a brief introduction
uh what you will see on the platform is
project so a project is the key
organization units that we have on
digital hub every single project if they
are a separate entity uh in that like
they contain
independent applications storage files
database all of these applications they
are integrated and installed within
minutes when you start a project they're
integrated with the database they are
connected with the file storage and they
are accessible with single sign-on
and of course with every single project
you have uh all the users that um goes
into the project they get assigned to
different projects um these users you
can give them actually a role-based um a
user access that actually just
automatically get propagated into all of
the applications within that project
and then one of the main key features
that we have on this project is data
flow so we wanted to streamline the data
flow as much as possible so what it
actually might look like is that we have
a jupiter lab environment which you can
see in kind of the schematic here on the
left here we would have a jupiter
environments that serve as the core
central development
environment during the data science
project projects
and then this jupiter environment you
can actually have it once your data is
ready to go push it into the different
databases that's associated to different
projects and go inside the dashboarding
applications inside say project a it's
already automatically integrated with
that database so i can just simply push
my data into the database navigate over
to my dashboarding application and start
working on my dashboard so there's no
more integrations in between everything
is streamlined and ready to go
so to the map itself um it's an open
source platform everyone can get access
to it um
what's special about jupiter lab on our
digital hub here is that we have already
customized it for data science so we
pre-installed it with a lot of the
popular language kernels along with the
most popular data science libraries that
we often use all with these languages so
python and r
we have a shared folder for team
collaborations so every single project
on the digital hub here you can see a
shared folder within the jupyter lab in
which all of your members when they
launch up into their jupyter map
instance have access to so all those
files are synchronized
just to streamline that team
collaboration process
we have again as i mentioned the
notebook templates on real world on
guest use cases so some of the use case
and some of the techniques in guiding
you how to approach a problem say if
it's a time series analysis or a machine
learning analysis
and also the lastly we have a
pre-installed or some of the most
popular data science extensions uh
inside the jubilee lab environment here
so yokonda you manage different
environments get
for version control and attacks which is
a nice
extension for doing conversions between
the book and script and a lot more
others but here's a few examples
then we have these open source um
business analytics and visualization
applications so super set very popular
for bi purposes building very very nice
dashboards but then you can just do
click and drop uh when you're building
the dashboard i will be also going
through it a little bit at the end of
the workshop here just showcasing a
dashboard on supersets and how you can
build
that dashboard with the
prediction results that we have from a
use case
and grafana which is a very popular time
series dashboard optimize for time
series visualizations and actually do
exceptions reporting and monitoring of
an alert
so just another few key points on here
so with the digital hub platform we want
to make it um easiest for you uh when
you do governance team management and
cost control so again with team settings
just add invites people into different
projects um and then for in terms of
cost control you can always choose to
start it launch and post in applications
just need to to run based on the need
so if all that broke about digital hub
makes you slightly interested in digital
hub feel free to come on to
cloud.digitalhub.io on here uh and then
you can register for accounts we have a
few plans that is available in academia
individual and teamspan so if we go in
and subscribe to plan and then just
create a project and explore away
so now we can actually go in to the um
use case itself
i'll be talking to a little bit more
about but at this point um because we're
gonna dive into the use case and go into
jupiter notebook and do all the hands-on
session is there any questions at this
point that you can answer
there is none in the chat so if no one
talks you can go on
right
that's good
okay
so going into the
uh use case itself this use case is on
the electrical power output uh and this
is what actually becomes very important
is the accurate predictions of these
power outputs they become very important
in making economical and operation
decisions uh and if you have the right
buy and sell decisions um according to
how your dietary plans is performing you
can actually save millions of dollars so
in this um hands-on section what we're
going to do is that it's a little bit of
a two-part process so we're going to go
through first the data science part of
it um doing the energy production
prediction uh with a day in science
model
and then the second part of it will be a
market analysis so how we take that
predictions plug it in with a forecast
um price uh for forecast market price
for electrical energies and then come up
with a recommended market action
so because everything in here uh really
this workshop is all about processes uh
it's key to note that like we'll just be
doing a very general um guide tutorial
through how the entire data science
process looked like really every single
part of um that stage their data
exploration feature engineering
machinery model building those deserve a
workshop of its own um but you can kind
of think of it as kind of this workshop
and what we outlined here is how you can
bring all of these processes together
into one big picture
with that i'm going to navigate over to
my browser here um before we go into the
notebook i'll actually just show you a
little bit on the platform here i might
have to lock him again as i do
uh so this you can come into the
platform through cloud.digitalhub.io
and then sign up for accounts here you
can click on there but i'm just gonna
login
so this is uh how our
uh
digital hub looks like uh you have a
home page where we have some resources
some past tutorials and webinars we've
done
ourselves and then some blogs if you're
interested in uh you can see in my
um projects here i already have several
projects going on with different sort of
analysis um particularly this one will
be looking at power plant energy
predictions but before you can pre uh go
on to and create any projects you will
need a subscription with us which you
can just navigate to and explore a
little bit more in the pricing page here
um
either child to get in your plan for
free or um you can also contact us um
for a demo on the platform if you're
interested in itself um but this is just
a very quick look at what the platform
looks like
so you can see on here if i navigate to
my project i have a superset and the
final instance and also my jupiter um
that is running right now um right now i
don't have my superset running but i'm
just gonna launch it up right now so
it's ready to go once we're done with
the notebook
so i'm gonna go through the notebook on
here um
sorry so the notebook uh i have a github
repository that contains
the notebook and the data sets
in here
and also we there is a quick uh pdf
document for the latter part of the
workshop where we are going to go into
supersets and actually building that
production dashboard
so this link is already inside the slack
channel so if you're inside the section
on the pi data it's already there feel
free to go in and just
pull the repository and then just
follow along the notebook as well
but for 10 purposes and this webinar i
already pre-run the notebook um so that
we are can go to the notebook smoothly
okay so if i said this is uh the problem
domain is in the electrical uh
generations of a
combined cycle power plant so i have
taken a open data set from uci machinery
repository for the powerpad data and
then what i have taken for the market
analysis part of it is a pool price of
the electrical market prices forecast
data from aeso which is the alberta
electrical surface operators um because
we're in algorithm also we're in canada
in here whereas the province that we're
in so this is kind of like the official
place where we have all those
theological market data
so you can go through the notebooks here
a little bit of the required libraries
in here um i've pulled out the tape of
content on the side here so you can
follow along at which that we are at for
the notebook
um
so again every single part of these
sections in here deserves a very good uh
workshop of its own reality but in this
case we're just gonna really present the
ideas of what happens in every single
step here so you have a big general idea
of when you approach data science
project what's kind of the process that
looks like
so first off when i get the data of
course the first thing you're gonna do
is explore all the data you want to know
how big of a data you want to work and
what are the features you're working
with and if there are any problem inside
the data as a matter of fact
so if i just pull out the
energy um the electrical plants data in
here i can see that i have about
9568 data points that is collected from
that power plant over six years when
there was work in full force uh some of
the variables that i have in here is
temperature uh on an hourly basis uh
temperature the exhaust vacuum pressure
um the ambient pressure and the relative
humidity
and of course then we have um the record
of the hourly energy output of that hour
for that tent
so in this case with the prediction
problem that we're going with this is
obviously a supervised learning problem
where we already have our predicting
variable in here and then the rest of
these environments related data is going
to be our predictors
so for
a um bpa analysis on here i am using a
package called pandas profiling which is
a very neat package um that you can
install and then what it actually does
is that once you have give it a data set
it provides you a very nice interface um
with doing a lot of the basic uh summary
statistic analysis for you so right away
i can see the number of observations so
remember how big of a data i'm working
with uh the number of features that i
have how many of them are numerical how
many is categorical if i'm missing cells
i don't have any duplicate rows it's a
very nice summary on here i can also go
into different variables in here and
just take a look at every single one of
them what are the summary statistics
that's returning and also distributions
of it so looking through my variables
here um there's not too much of a
outlier problem um there's also no
missing data problem which is very nice
for a data set um this is usually kind
of the stage of the data of how you want
it to look like by the end of the data
wrangling
uh there's maybe a little bit of problem
in terms of normality of my variables in
here um but that just excess of um data
itself the nice part is you can also
look at interactions um to the
interactions of different variables on
here look at how they look like uh if
you want to see a just a correlation
heat map that's also available inside
this widgets here it's a very nice
budget that for you to look at
but overall just scrolling through the
data sets there um i see that there's no
really significant need for any more
data wrangling this is probably assuming
that it's already done
there's no really any outliers so i need
some data in my data set so i can just
really go on forward to the next part of
my analysis there though i didn't notice
there's a bit of high correlations
between my features um that might serve
become a problem later on in model
building for these inter correlations
but that's just something to keep in
mind
so the next set of data that i'm looking
at is the market data so the pool price
forecast data that i got from aeso um
took it from the time uh this is the
exact same timeframe that i have with my
energy beta
uh so what it's showing is the forecast
full price um the actual price of that
uh the energy during that hour um they
had forecasts for the internal loads and
the difference um but really we'll just
be using the forecast pro price um for
our analysis there um these forecast
profiles they were made two hours in
advance um to when the price uh is
actually quoted so for every single time
for a physical hour you will have to
forecast for the next two hours that's
um how it works on the aeso there
a little bit of parsing on the date time
discuss on the
page variable that uh is returned from
the extracts of that data there is not
possible by pandas uh sorry by python so
there's a little bit of data wrangling
for the daytime variable there in here
so is there any questions about the data
at this point uh i will continue on
forward i don't think i see anything in
the chat so i'll just keep on going
so the next part uh that you would do
anyway with the coming into any data
machine learning process is you want to
split up your data um in general how
that looks like is for
what you would want to do is that you
want to hold out a portion of your data
that you won't touch until the very very
very very end because what this is um
coming into
is that
you want to make sure that the model
that you have by the end of the process
is going to be able to generalize um so
this is coming into the problem for
optimization bias and overfitting um
sometimes you use the data so much uh
and retraining the model so much getting
to a point where you see a very nice
accuracy or a very nice metric on the
performance but in the end maybe that
model is just performing very well on
your training set of data and once you
generalize it to data that you haven't
seen before
that's where it's gonna go wrong
so that's also known as the golden rule
a general practice um might be to split
up into a training set that's about 60
testing set 20 validation which is the
hold up set to be 20
um but for this notebook we're going to
use a concept
called cross validations uh it was so
that my i would just put up my data set
into 80 for my working data and then the
last 20 percent as my validation hold up
set
so in case you're not familiar with the
concept of cross-fold validations there
is a little group in here uh just
showing you what that looks like um so
in general what this is trying to do is
to bring out the most from the data so
pretty much um you can think of it as
every single observations that you have
in your data sets is eventually once
going to serve as the training set um in
training the model and serve once as the
validation of testing sets uh in testing
out your model uh
for the performance metric
so there's a nice little diagram in here
that shows you how how that will work so
in this case we're splitting the data
that we're working with so this would be
my 80 data not the 20 hotel just the 80
we're splitting that 80 again into five
different sections and then for each
section um
we're going to perform a model building
and the model evaluations so then in the
first time i may take out the first
section as kind of my test set so that
is where i do my body evaluation while
the rest of the four sets sections will
be used for training the model and then
the next round i'm gonna use the second
portion as testing and the rest of the s
training and third round so on and so
forth and eventually your final
performance metric is going to be an
average of the evaluation performance
vector from each of these iterations
like that in your cross code validations
so this is really just a way uh for us
to be able to really take uh use the
most out of the data um that we have
this is especially useful if your data
set is relatively small um in which
maybe holding out um 20
already for validation and just taking
60 percent of your data for training and
20 for testing um that could also kind
of come into a lot uh with
uh might step into something both the
bias variance trade-offs and also the
overfitting there
you can
so then we'll be using cross-validations
um
as we go on forward uh with notebook
here uh so for every uh wherever we do a
hyperparameter tuning we have to retest
and retrain our model um we'll be using
the password validations
so let's say i split up my data here so
you can kind of look at how it looks
like so i did 80 of my data um so that's
really now a training size about 7 800
observations and then my validation set
um for about 20
and because we have that um last part of
the forecast analysis i've reserved out
about one week's worth of time at the
end of the data sets there for that
market analysis
so in this case uh how i split up my
training on the validation sets is i
just took the last three months as my
validation set and then the first part
of it as my training set so this is kind
of imitating um the model where your
model is built on past data and then it
has to predict on future data so this is
just um for this case it makes sense uh
in some other problems it might make
actually more sense if you shuffle up
your data so then you take a random
portion a random subset of um 80 as your
trading size and then random subset of
validations as your validation size
that's uh pretty dependent on the
problem
so the next part uh we have to split up
our data we finished cleaning it we
finished wrangling it we did a bit of
data exploration analysis now now we're
gonna do a little bit of feature
engineering
so from my um and i'll show initial
exploration of my data i already know
that there i have some numerical
variable that i'm working with uh
there's some
categorical variable that i'm working
with um
intervals specifically just for the
daytime render um so then like now i can
do a little bit more feature engineering
uh so this is the feature
transformations and sort of implications
outliers handling binding features
building feature applications
of those
i've also linked a recommended read here
for some of the fundamental techniques
of feature engineering if you want to go
and read a little bit more about it
so it's very important to know that what
transformation engineering techniques as
well for your data
um in this data set uh we don't have any
outliers we don't really have any
missing data which is nice um but most
of the features uh have some large
ranges um so then we might consider uh
doing some sort of vlog transformations
on it and
in terms of this um when deciding what
sort of feature engineering you do a
specifically you have to know what works
best for your data is that so the
numerical variables are the ranges of
those numerical variables versus
categorical variables and also the model
that you're considering training so some
models they might actually work very
nicely with some transformations like k
n being a distance based model
might work very well when you apply log
transformations to a numerical variable
versus applying log transformations on
your numerical variables might not make
much of a difference when you're using a
decision tree which would actually show
a little bit more down this
notebook here
and just one very key important uh thing
to keep in mind that i have seen people
focus very commonly um mistakes into is
that whatever transformations that
you're applying to your training set you
want to do the exact transformation on
your validation set so just a quick
example and here say i'm doing
normalizations um for my ambient
pressure in here uh so for
normalizations we need to know the
minimum uh value inside the for this
feature and the maximum value for this
feature um those are two parameters that
we need uh to apply normalizations
so i have the min and max here for my
training set which is 993 to 1033 uh so
in this case when i apply this
transformation on my validation set
i am using the same maximum that i have
for my training sets not the maximum
that i have for my validation set so
this is just a
common common thing that is so easy to
fall into
when you're doing um feature
transformations
can i
there are two questions in the in the
chat do you want to take them now or
oh sure uh actually i'll just finish
maybe this last party in future
engineering and then i'll click on
projects yeah
uh okay so i just did a quick code in
here um i coded up a class object for
doing the transformation pipeline uh
just to showcase a little bit in terms
of uh if you know about coding you can
read through it um to see how that uh
features engineering is kind of
works out in the back end um so how it
tracks all the parameters um how it
tracks on the different types of feature
engineering techniques that you're going
through
and then transform the features for you
so this is just for demonstration
purpose a lot of time when we're
actually working on the data science
problem there is a lot of machine
learning packages out there like second
learn that already provide a lot of
powerful engineering functions for you
um but this is just for a demonstration
purpose that you can look through um and
get a good understanding on how the
feature transformation looks like
uh so in here i can show uh i have
applied that transformation pipeline
that i have on my training sets um so i
fit it and transformed my training set
in here you can see from the code here
and then i simply just transformed my
validation set to the same pipeline so
it didn't refit on the transformation
pipeline from validation set you simply
just use the same fitted uh pipeline and
then transform your validation sets
there just re-emphasizing that point
okay uh so that was feature engineering
uh now we will go a little bit more into
machine learning model building and i'll
also take a look at the chat here for
the questions
yeah so first question was how
correlated or data points that are next
to each other
have you tried temporal cross validation
so it was a bit earlier
okay
okay so with the things that um next to
each other so we i didn't do um temporal
cross validations at this point um with
the data set i had on there because from
my dependence profiling i think at that
point what i saw on there was that there
is actually very high correlations
between the energy output and some of
the variables already so like
temperature and humidity so in that case
um for me actually at that point i was
thinking i was doing regression analysis
more than a machine learning model but
um
in that case i didn't do temporal cross
violation but that would be very
interesting um to look at as well so
that is definitely a good point
um to do as well
and press for the temporal cost
validations uh if you look into the
actual data sets from the uc machine
learning repository there's no time on
there we added in the date time
ourselves um for the purpose of this
demonstration
[Music]
and the second question is about the
data was is why is ambient pressure an
interesting variable
uh that came out uh when we were talking
about future engineering or it's just uh
in general um
so
uh the embryonic pressure um it's
definitely a
important feature in terms of how the
power plant works um so uh the ambiance
pressure of that power plant it affects
quite um actually uh quite significantly
in terms of the amount of energy you can
output
during that hour and from just the way
the energy plant works uh in terms of
why i'm using ambient pressure as kind
of the just the
example here for the transformations um
i kind of just chose ambient pressure
because it started with an a um but if
you look through the transformations
pipeline in here uh and then at the end
i applied the transformations for the
ambient pressure and actually i did the
um pretty much the same transformations
for um relative humidity and the excel
spectrum and relative humidity so
oh and temperature sorry uh so then like
because these are all numerical
variables i want to apply some sort of
normalization or standardizations to
them so
i don't know that was the question
um okay
so uh maybe a little bit more on like
this transformation so what i decided to
do again was i'm just doing
standardization normalizations on these
numerical variables here uh and then for
my date time uh instead of just
happening as a big time variable i
extract out the month of the time uh and
then also doing uh just
in terms of um the date it's kind of
grouped it into was it in the beginning
of the month so like the first 10 days
uh middle of the month or the end of the
month and then put it out with one hot
encoding um and dealing with kind of
transforming into more like a
categorical variable
so now going into the machine learning
uh model building itself um
i'm going to look at um two basic uh
machine learning models so we have the
support factor regressor and also the
decision tree regression so these are um
the
regression version of svm and decision
trees um classifications and then so but
in this case we're doing a regression uh
for the
um problem here uh so the support vector
model again is a distance based
algorithm so you might you're gonna see
a big difference when we apply
standardization and normalizations on
our numerical features versus um what we
did in transformational features whereas
in the decision tree will be less
dependent on these type of
transformations um
if you want to learn about more about
different machine learning models um the
second learn user guide actually
provides very good references to um how
all these different machine learning
models work
and also there is a very nice um blog
article here
by perishing that actually introduces
quite quite well on the basics of the
machine learning models
so you can see in here i have applied
the
support vector model and the decision
tree model on both the transform data
and the end transforms data
so this is just prior to redoing any
sort of
hyper parameter tuning i'm just using
the default state uh default um
configurations um from the um so i could
learn machine learning packages
and then doing cross validations
on the data sets when they are
transformed and the data so when they're
not transformed
in the case when they're not transformed
because we can't really deal with date
time variables uh dropped i just simply
dropped the datetime variables on those
so with the
transformation scores on here you can
see that with a um svr machine learning
model um
you can see there's a very big
difference so then once we have
transformed the data applied that
standardization transformation we have
about 2.92 uh with our violation score
when we didn't transform it we were at
about 0.3
in contrast uh when we applied it to a
decision tree regressor uh the
difference isn't that big 0.97
versus 0.921 um the difference in there
is not huge
so this is just a score summary in here
you can see that like the svr model and
the decision model if i round it up um
the best it went was 0.92 um on the data
set there and then when we didn't
transform it on the svm1 just
significantly worse
so from here um because
uh for demonstration purpose only um if
you look into all those little scores at
the end uh the svr model after on the
transform data uh gave us the best score
in this case so we're just going to use
the svr model um
as we go on forward with the hyper
parameter tuning
now usually on the real life situations
we will actually still go on forward to
the decision tree model um just because
maybe um perhaps you have a parameter on
the decision tree it would work a lot
better but this is for demonstration
purpose only that we just decided to go
with the sbr model for the rest of the
notebook
so
feature engineering was working on the
features and working on the data hyper
parameter tuning is working on the model
so
in terms of hyper parameter tuning uh
there's a little bit verb on here uh and
then also a nice quote and a blog in
here explaining a little bit more in
depth what hyper parameter tuning is but
eventually in general uh what happens
for every single model or machine
learning model that you decide to go
with there is parameters and then there
is hyper parameters you can think of
hyperparameters as kind of like the
rules that you give to the model when
it's training um to let them know what
the parameters should be in
so say for a decision tree some of the
hyperparameter that you might set for
the model when it's training is what's
the max death of the tree so how many
times it can make a decision
um and also maybe if a feature that you
make a decision on so in a decision
stump can it be used more than once uh
throughout the training process so these
like rules that you give to the model uh
and then parameters though what they
what they are is when the model actually
fits to the data set that you have
it's deciding on which feature is you're
going to use at a particular decision
stump uh what values are to make the
decisions on and what is eventually the
depth of the actual depth of the
decision tree once it's finished
training so
in this case um so setting up the hyper
parameters are setting out the right
rules uh for your machine learning model
to know what it's working
within a scope of that's going to
what's eventually going to affect um the
performance of the model
so now that's just a little general grip
on hypergraphic tuning again you can
read a little bit more on there um
there's a few blocks on there that you
can go in and read um
in this case uh we're gonna go with svr
model uh in general if you look into the
documentations for the sr model on sega
learn um there is three hyper parameters
that we're going to be playing with so
one is the kernel which is the function
that is used to classify and do the
regressions on um
so these are categorical so there's
linear poly on the acetone uh and then
there's a c value which is the
regularization parameters um so this
control how generalized your model is uh
and then we also have gamma which is the
kernel coefficient for specifically if
you want to go with the rbf poly of
sigmoid kernel functions
and for these ones um you can either
give it a numerical variable or you can
just add it through auto or scale mode
uh where the
gamma is dependent on it
so again to learn more a little bit uh
in details uh into what these office
codes are you can always go to this i
could learn user guide they provide very
good references and documentations on
there
uh and then but now we're actually going
to go to the hyperbaric tuning process
itself um there are three two sorry two
very general mode in how we do
hyperparameter tuning so there is the
grid search and then there's the
randomized search so a grid search um
you get a list uh or the limits of the
paper parameters uh and then it goes
through an exhaustive um
goes through the list exhaustively and
then it trains the model and score for
every single combination of the
hyperbola determinant uh and then with
the randomized search where instead of
giving an exact list or limits of these
type of parameters you give the
distributions or just a bound of those
high parameters and then it just do a
very randomized samples of
a combinations of these hyper parameters
and train and tune in those defined
spaces
so we're going to go through each of
these um
inside the notebooks just to demonstrate
how they look like so again a little bit
of pros and cons with the grid search
you're doing a very exhaustive search of
your hyperparameters so say if you have
a important parameter uh on one hand
here and then programmer two on the
x-axis here the grid search goes through
every single one of it um in terms of
the exhaustive combinations whereas in a
randomized search it's taking a random
sample of combinations so
the grid search is going to be very
costly on timing computations whereas
the randomized layer is usually what we
would use when we first start out with
hypergramic tuning so very common
processes um usually we start out with
randomized layer uh with the randomized
search we then we can kind of get an
idea of what are the thousand um
the balance of the hyperparameter that
works best and then we slowly use that
um maybe apply now the randomized search
but for smaller bounds and smart about
and eventually use the bridge search um
to exhaustively search through all the
combinations once you have a very idea
of a smaller bound
and the smaller set of hyper parameters
that you have
so for a demonstration purpose on me on
here uh we wanted a very small squid
shirt um was just um two
so i gave it the options here for just
two uh kernels um two c feathers and two
gamma values um so doing a research um
this is a total of eight different
combinations so what it did is that it
trained the model eight times on each
combinations um and because it was a
five volt cross validation so that is
total of forty fits and then it
calculates out what is the best score
for you and then what are the best
parameters in this case
so then i also ran um the quiz search a
little bit more uh you can see from the
commented out um sections in here um
on the back end and just show you a
little bit more in terms of how that
looks like
now again with the randomized search um
so the pros and cons i think have to
mention uh in contrast with grid search
usually it's better at the very
beginning when you're just kind of doing
an initial exploration of your
hyperparameter space there
uh in this case you can see from a
difference on there uh the kernel it's
still a just a mess because these are
categorical um variables um for them uh
so categorical choice and then before
c's and gamma instead of a list of the
values i gave it a distribution so this
was a lot of uniform distributions uh
with range and then for both c and gamma
and then so in contrast to
grid search where it was it already knew
that it was doing eight um combinations
uh in this case i have to specify to it
um do eight so that we can do a um fair
comparisons between the randomized
search and the quick search
so in this case again you can get the
best um score out of your rhythmized
search um function here and then the
best parameters comes in i also did a
run of this randomized search of 100
iterations is up eight i'll talk about
11 minutes to finish uh and then this
was the result that it came back so it
did a little bit more of a search in
that space and came up with a best score
that was slightly better than the ones
that we did when we just did eight um
iterations
[Music]
so after something that like
we would do after exploring of doing
some of the scriptures here is that we
want to explore the hyperparameter space
so you want to limit out to a space of
the hyperparameter that where you
actually get better um performance model
so in this case um
i already ran um the i took the
randomized search data from when we ran
that 100 um iterations uh and then
created a quick visualization on here
just to uh with a few of the parameters
so then this is how it looks like when
the kernel was linear uh when the
canon's rbf versus kernel when it was
pulling
and then on the y-axis here it's a
little bit small to see but it's the
gamma and then on the x-axis this is c c
value and then the color of it is the
performance of the model so you can see
um
this is just kind of conceptualizing how
you explore kind of like the high
parameter space um i can see that the
model performs pretty well inside the
space here
the space here and the space there so
then like the next iterations hyper
parameter tuning that i might do is then
i'm going to redefine my bounds uh for
those distributions uh and to just limit
it to the space the space in the space
do another end of my search and slowly
just limit it down move further and
further and further until you get to the
best set of high parameters that you
have for your model
so that's just kind of the process there
for hyper primary tuning
um
eventually i
so in this case i'm just going to assume
that with this i'm good enough i have a
hyper parameter model that gave me best
uh score for super nine three and that
is already good enough for my model so
i'm just gonna go ahead and use this on
rank uh password score here and i'm just
gonna continue on forward now with my
model evaluations
okay
so with model evaluations there's a few
um basic model uh
of how you can actually do a evaluations
the most basic evaluation as users
compare the train and test score using
new different models um so we have the
base model where i was just using just
the default svr
from the package there and then our
optimized model now with um those hyper
parameters that gave us best the best
scores
so in this case we can see it went from
zero point nine two two super nine three
almost two point nine four for the um
training set and then we went from 2.90
for the test scores to 0.93 for the um
test scores on here
but just in case you don't know if this
difference going from 0.90 to super nine
three was significant enough to tell you
that um this optimized model is doing
better than the base model there is
always statistical evaluations that you
do so in this case this is just an
example of the ring cousins rank test
in this case what it actually does is
that it utilizes
the feature for cross validation because
of course cross validations you have
those um say five fourth cross
validations you would have five test
scores so then that now becomes kind of
the population sample that you're um
doing your statistical tests on
and then using comparing the samples um
the five samples you have for that base
base model and the five samples that we
have from an optimized model it does a
statistical test on it where the known
value is that they are not significantly
different from each other and then of
course you have your p values uh in this
case is smaller than 0.25 so we would
conclude that it is significantly
different so in this case i'm using this
test in here of course it's showing a
usual warning that our sample size is
too small
but
assuming that this is a valid test uh i
would say that our trade uh hyper
parameter tuned
optimized model is performing
significantly better than a base model
so the last part here now let's say i'm
completely happy with the optimized
model that we have with the svr now this
is where the holdout validation set
comes in so this is a set against it was
never used through the entire notebook
except for the transformation parts um
being used in the machine learning model
anywhere so then now i'm going to
perform that validation uh oh sorry
perform the predictions on the
validation set here and then take the
score out of it so we can see that with
the base model validations um 0.92 and
then with the optimization 0.937
so in this case because my
validation score is not that much
different from the score that i had just
looking at it with the test scores and
the
um in the above section above cell there
so in this case our model is actually
able to be generalized very fairly well
on this new set of data in the
validation set that has never seen
before
another common thing uh to
look at your model through is to look at
the residuals
so that you want to ensure that your
model is not going through any sort of
bias um
then looking at the residuals is where i
will tell you that so the residuals is
the difference between your predicted
value and the actual value for your
predictor prediction so you'll find uh
your vat well sorry your y variable so
in this case our energy um that we're
trying to predict
so what you want to see is that you want
to see a fairly randomized cluster
around zero so in this case we have a
few outliers um but that doesn't seems
like too much of a problem where you
would see a problem is that if your um
residuals goes in a very obvious trend
upward downward or curved if you see a
very obvious trend that is where um you
want your model is having some sort of
bias problem
so that's the residuals part is one way
of looking at it um the qq plot and for
the normalized residuals is another way
of just um visualizing that so you want
to see a very
um bell shaped uh
distributions symmetric normal
distributions around zero for the
quantiles again so we have a few
outliers which was the same as we've
seen from the graph valve and also for
the cubic parts here you want it to
align fairly well with um that red line
there again we see a little bit tail off
because of those outliers
and then the last part of course is the
most exciting part is that you actually
compare um your predictive value with
the actual values so you can of course
anytime put the put all the plots
together uh in this case i use ploppy so
that we can have a little bit more
interactions with it but you can see
that um the actual and the predictor
values and how they um the differences
between them attention but they're not
doing anything too drastically wrong
so that would actually come uh concludes
our part for the machine learning model
building itself is there any questions
on that before i move on to the market
analysis we'll now bringing in the
forecast and
dumping that business context on top of
it
is there any questions
quickly here
or there is no question in the chat oh
maybe one coming yes
using a validation data set
okay
so
i would say there's not uh in terms of
gain i would say more of like the
benefits of using a validation data set
is that you ensure that your model is
not overfitting so the whole purpose of
the validation set is that it is a set
of data that your model has not seen
before during the entire model building
process what is a common thing that
could happen when you're model building
because you're working on that same set
of data so much and you're tuning up
your um
validation score also enough value score
your accuracy score to that um data set
what is a common problem is called
overfitting so your model ends up doing
very well on that training set
and then it doesn't know what to do when
you actually give it things that you
haven't seen before because it's just
fitted so well to that set all the way
to the little um crins and nyx inside
the data set that when you give it a set
of data you haven't seen before it can't
generalize so it ends up doing very bad
on the validation set so
doing
that's a little over fitting about the
test set no because the test set is also
things that i have seen inside the
training process so we use the test sets
um for us to know uh
you can think of it in this way so the
test set uh tells you when you're
training a bunch of different models
which model does better than the other
but eventually
once you have selected that model that
does the best out of it
then that to ensure that that model is
not having any overfitting problem then
you apply the validation set over it to
let the note to see how well it
generalized because all in all the test
set is also part of that working data
that you're working with in the model
building process um
it has seen that data before so the
whole golden rule is that you have to
validate it on data but it hasn't seen
before
answer some questions
so there is another one have you seen
any case any cases where under fitting
shows up
ah
okay
yes so under fitting it's quite popular
as well so in terms of under fitting uh
so that just indicates to us that your
model um
again because machine learning and in a
sense it's a technical process and in a
sense as an art because when you're
doing data science and machine learning
it's all about that balance that you
find between bias and variance
overfitting and under fitting being
accurate enough but also being
generalized enough so it's all about
managing that balance so then in the
cases where we have seen understanding
of yes so it performs very well on our
um data set there and that it doesn't
perform as well on the
um validation set there but oftentimes
uh with the under fitting it also gives
you signs when you were just training
um
model so that when you're training uh
and your test score doesn't perform as
well that's usually cases of
underfitting um and then in this case of
how you can fix it
you just have to go back and
uh so this is actually very common cases
in this case we were having a very
general example where we only have one
validation set but a lot of time in real
life
when your data set is big enough um
people tend to hold up several parts of
the validation set so we will have
values instead one is step two set three
step four step five um so then like
once you have um you you use the first
validation set you can skip the prop uh
get insights into whether you're
overfitting or under fitting on there um
you optimize that part and then once you
get a score that's big enough then you
apply the second set of validations to
ensure that like whatever you did on top
uh what after you get more insight from
your validation set is actually solving
your problem
so then with under fitting um the main
solvent really is just you do better
on future selections feature engineering
again all the process we've talked about
here um maybe it's a problem in your
data that um your data is not working
well for the model that you're training
it with or it might be the model hyper
parameter so maybe there is a space that
you missed um against with the
randomized search um because like it
might just randomly have not go into
that space that it performs the best um
that is a chance so maybe you just have
to do another randomized search to make
sure that you're getting a idea of that
full parameter space and knowing exactly
where that good part is
uh and then like with the hypermeter
another thing that like um you can mess
with is the regularization parameter so
a lot of the model machine learning
model there's a regularization parameter
that controls the generalized um aspects
of the machine learning models so that's
regularization parameters or even other
recognization techniques um that comes
on top of the models it's all the things
that you can consider when fixing an
underfitting problem
hope that answers it uh
there's something else i'll just go on
for it um because of time's sake i just
want to get through this market analysis
part as well uh if you have any more
questions about data science and model
building uh you can always go to the
slack channel after the um
uh the webinars here and then i can
do a little bit more answering there as
well and i believe my link then is also
on the profile page so if you want to um
chat do linkedin that's what that's also
possible
okay so now uh we have
that forecast set of data so remember
that last one weak set of data that i
extracted of the entire data sets for
this forecast analysis um so
with the uh again so this is how the
data set looks like this is raw data set
uh what i'm going to do is that i'm
going to transform it with that exact
same pipeline that i have again i didn't
fit it i just simply transformed it uh
and then i
do my i predict
uh model uh the energy output uh for
this forecast set of data using the
model that we had to that best model
that we had
and now i append it to this data set
here
so that was just getting the forecasting
parts of my energy output so now i'm
gonna go in and merge in with the market
data that i got from aeso based on the
time uh values on here so now i have i
know what i predicted for that hour what
my energy output is and aeso has given
me a forecast pro price for that hour
so with these two um variables uh what
we can do now uh is that for a power
plants they always know what their
internal loads are in this case i don't
have the data on that so i simulated a
internal load for that power plant for
that hour
uh and then with the some of the reports
here from the usdia uh we i have the
average localized cost of what how much
it takes to produce electricity in a
combined cycle power plants so now
there's few things that we have we know
the internal demand
so how much our power plants need to run
we have predictions of how much our
power plants can produce in that hour
we know the cost of the productions and
we have the forecast pro price of what
that what electricity price looks like
in the market at that hour so with these
four things then we can apply just
actually a very simple market logic on
top of it so if my production cost is
going to be higher than that price in
the market then i would just buy off my
demand from the market because it's just
it's cost less that way
but if my production cost is less than
the price um that is on the market then
like there's two scenarios either from
our prediction of electricity production
uh we either have a shortage so whatever
we can produce in that hour is less than
our internal demand in that case we will
produce whatever we have and then we buy
the rest from the market
if we have a surplus so whatever we can
produce is higher than our internal
demand then we will produce all the
as much as we can and then sell our
servers to the market and get back a
little bit of money that way
so this is just a very simple logic uh
applied through a bunch of if else or
aware statements with numpy um so in the
end in here what i have produced as a
result is a
set of
data sets here that just shows me um
what's my internal demand at that hour
um what this i call the access um but
it's pretty much the difference between
my production and my demand
if it is a shortage or a surplus at that
hour
what is the cost if i produce everything
uh what is the cost if i just buy
my demand from the market
or if i just buy um only the shortages
from the markets and then what is the
price that i can get back if i sell the
service the markets and then at the end
what is the recommended actions um
uh in terms of like are we just
producing uh our
costs and buying our shortages we're
producing and then selling interpreters
or are we just buying our demand from
the market and then eventually we have
the net um
cost um after we have applied that
market action
so with jupiter notebook and using my
product you can put but there's some
pretty nice visuals already on here with
energy so then in terms of the shortage
and surpluses throughout each hour so
how much was the shortage also service
uh you can also
uh plot out your net cost on here and
then what are the um recommended actions
so these are very nice graphs inside the
notebook in here but ultimately
whenever you present to your market
partners generally they're not going to
be very appealing to the idea that they
have to run a notebook
and only see the graphs in the notebook
so this is where now we're going to go
into our dashboard and start building
that up uh so that they can open up a
nice dashboard and see pretty visuals
but in terms of uh just a quick part
scene here i didn't run this part
because i already have ran it um pushing
my data into that database i have for
the markets but then this on a digital
hub platform here how we have
so as i've mentioned how we streamline
that process for the data flow uh what
we have actually already done is that
when you log into your jupyter lab
environment you would already have your
uri so your connection string to your
database uh inputted as an environmental
variable for you
so then with this notebook uh and then i
can just simply grab that um
environmental variable from the terminal
or you can just simply
uh replace the power plant energy
prediction with the name of your uh
project on capital uh and then just load
in my data that way and then just put
everything in with sql coming
so this is uh just a quick note on the
notebook on here
uh and then
yes yeah so it is on
yes so
thank you everyone for helping me post
uh get a link onto the uh
chat there so yes this notebook uh and
also a set of instructions of what
you're going to see
on building the dashboard and superset
is uh inside this github repository here
so you the notebook is here from pi data
notebook uh and then the creating energy
production this is going to what you're
going to see in this next parts here
okay
so i'm just gonna so that wraps it up
for the notebook i'm just gonna show you
quickly of what happens on the dataset
there um
so you can see our um i started my
superset instance before we go into the
notebook now it's ready to go so i'm
just gonna simply go in and launch it up
okay
so what you're going to see here i'm
just going to show you what it looks
like
in general
so this is a dashboard that i have built
out based on that market predictions um
that we have and also the united states
predictions so what you can see in here
on the dashboard is there's a little bit
of a time filter that you can filter for
in this case because we're using on past
data that was a year ago i didn't have
any time field range on this but the
nice part about this um dashboard is
that as
say you're already in production
environments and you're ingesting data
into the database on a timely basis you
can set out the time filter on here the
dashboard get updated real time as soon
as those data are inside the database
so here's something that i put together
that makes it uh easier to show and give
values actually the business value this
is where the business outcome comes in
is that
this uh the operators or the decision
makers they ultimately see that the
total estimate cost um if we follow the
recommendations that is offered by the
engine there is about uh 2.5 billion
this is only a week's worth of time by
the way
and if estimated if we just buy
everything from the market
which is about 4 million you're already
saving two millions in that one week uh
first is if you don't uh care about
anything and just estimate to full
production regardlessly uh in this case
you're gonna have a few shortages here
and there uh without buying anything
from the market you're still saving
about 0.1 million so about 100 000 is
there so
and the estimated total energy
production in that week is about um
72 000 megawatts
so then we have a little bit of uh chart
in here you can see it um just uh within
the last hours uh we have a little bit
of two percent increase in megawatts in
the last hours uh inside this week uh
how many times we have a shortage versus
sometimes we have a surplus on here
by day
in that last week how many time was the
decision to buy a load versus when you
um produce and buy the shortages versus
when you produce and sell this on
surplus
and again um the cost on here in your
estimated net cost versus your full
production cost and predicted service
and shortages um throughout the time of
that week
so this is just in general how that uh
looks like and can just do a very quick
demonstration of what you can do again
like um all of the
materials that you're gonna see there is
gonna be inside this pdf for creating
this energy production so we have
already put together a kind of like a
step-by-step um process in how um to put
that dashboard together
uh assuming you have a superset going on
so in this case anytime you start with a
superset instance you always need to
connect it with a data source so the
nice part about digital hub is that
whenever you launch up the superset from
a project that defaults database that
connects to your project database
already there so you can skip the step
but in other cases you're going to have
to connect it with other databases
uh inside any and then when you're
building charts you will first need to
define the tables so then um
after you have ingested those tables
into your database you just have to
simply come into the table sections here
and tell
superset what are the schema and what is
the table name that it needs to look
into
and then once you have all those tables
that is already ingested and superset
knows what those tables are then you can
simply go ahead and just click on new in
here you can either do a sql query on
the tables inside database you can build
a chart or you can build a dashboard so
in this case i'm just going to go in and
build a chart on here
again the first thing that you do so
that the data shows which would be the
tables that you have already defined for
the um super set so in this case i say
i'm doing markup predictions i'm going
to try to build that first chart with
the pie charts on here
and just simply create that chart
if you have seen was quick enough to see
there is a whole selection of different
chords that you can select uh with
superset and building on top of uh to
make very nice visualizations
in this case i'm going to take up my
time filter
and then i'm going to do a count
on my
surface versus shortage
uh
just gonna
do a count
and explore different options and see
what they get back
to shoot this
and they're just simply running the
query so in this case we already see
there's a shortage on here uh that's not
that one so it's
doing
something
yes that looks a little bit more correct
so now just with a few clicks here and
there and choosing the metrics and the
variables that you want i can get my pie
charts on here i can do a little bit of
more customizations i like it look more
like a donut or versus not i can show
the labels and i'll show you the labels
uh put in the batch and so forth but you
can choose this color scheme that you
like
uh so in how you do here and then once
you have gotten the chart that you like
you can save it
so i'm gonna call this my surface search
suggest pi
and right now i going to add it to a new
dashboard so in this case i can create a
dashboard in here this is my
name
save and i'm going to go to the
dashboard
so you can see that it's
and then as you have built in more
charts and more charts you can go ahead
and edit the dashboard
in this case then you can start with um
rearranging and dragging adding a new
charts in here um going through a bit of
customizations anywhere throughout the
dashboard on here and that's kind of
just
uh how you work it on superset but
eventually this is
um
again going through the whole context in
here for the workshop the business
um we spend a lot of time on building
the model itself that is um the machine
learning process and the data science
process of those are all the technical
work that have to go in to give you the
best results for the solution and the
problem but eventually what is going to
make sense to your business partner is
what they see on the dashboard in here
what is going to give them that visual
impact and then for them to see oh i can
save millions of dollars if i just go
with the solutions um
again you can see that like inside
throughout this notebook it was a fairly
simple problem uh we're just doing a
predictions on the electricity we apply
a fairly simple market logic engine on
it to come up with the recommendation
sections these are things of course it
can get a lot more complicated as you
try to
make things more accurate suits better
um to your customers to the enterprise
need um but eventually again going back
to that point it doesn't have to be a
complex problem for you to start off
something so a lot of time what we see
failures in is when we go into a
consultant um and we have a business
partner they have this very big grand
scheme of what they want to solve but
you just but they don't give you enough
time
or efforts or they're not willing to
spend that much uh time and efforts for
you to see that result on that grand
scheme so what you have to prove to them
is that you can take a small part of
that grand scheme
show them the value of what you can do
and then eventually when they are
convinced then you can start building
out on that grand scheme so that that is
uh i guess like just some
uh business insights um as things that i
have learned um when i was working on
data science consulting projects with
these oil and gas um clients and also
throughout when we were building digital
hub uh for the data science and clicking
into what where the enterprise needs uh
whenever we talk about data science in
the business context so we can't stay
alone in a little data science technical
um computer science world is often very
important and how you can communicate
your values to people who doesn't
understand data science doesn't
understand machine learning and for them
to see the value of what you can do
so i think that actually wraps up uh the
entire webinar series on here uh if
there are any more questions or like you
know i guess like we'll have a about 10
more minutes right now for any sort of
discussions or questions that we can and
answers here
okay there is one do you run into cases
that businesses wanted to see the model
results from um
let's see the model results
from so yes
hi
yeah hi this is sheila so
um i work a lot you know into this type
of hybrid environment where you know the
business is not as knowledgeable as the
as data and data science right and the
type of tools and models that we use
and sometimes you know they go the extra
step and say hey you know show me the
results from the model and tell me you
know why you decided to show to select
that model
so you know wanted to see you know what
was your experience at least on the
energy industry about what will be some
type of the results you know that you're
going to show them are you going to go
more into precision
will you be leading them more towards
accuracy and you know how to make it
like that business friendly
right um actually i do have an answer
with that so like from our past
experience what actually gave us the
best success was that throughout our
entire process of building that model
and building the solution there is one
subject matter expert that we will
always go to and we're in constant
communication with that subject matter
experts as we're building the solutions
so then like
whenever you made a milestone on the
solution itself uh it's often very
important to communicate how that works
to that supplementary experts and then
that's what their authorizer they also
have insights on their own maybe
sometimes like they say oh the accuracy
we don't want that we want something
like false positive or false negative
right because like that's going to be
what's going to be the critical matrix
to them in terms of the performance so
then that communication is what i found
to be very critical um so it's not like
you end communication from the very
beginning after you have uh completed
that whole process of
um hashing of the objectives but
throughout that model building process
as well it's very important to talk with
that subject matter experts and they can
also provide you with a lot of support
along the way as well um so
we had cases where
after we got to a certain point of the
model building um the social media
expert believed that it was good enough
of any mvps or minimal viable products
and they were happy with it that they
already wanted to see it being deployed
so that in the it was way before planned
but then that subject matter expert got
us um connected with the id department
so then like from there we already
started having discussions on um we have
this model here these are our
requirements um what does the ip
infrastructure looks like um what are
the things that we would have to do at
that point without the
solution being completely mature so
there was still a lot of rooms for
adjustments and modifications um for us
to be able to make our solution work
best customized for that um clients that
we had
so now that answers a question but like
in terms of um yes we had seen um
uh places where the client comes in and
say why does your model work that way um
and sometimes you may be able to answer
that uh with maybe the machine learning
model that
you use actually gives you back mattress
on what are the most important features
then like that is also like a good point
to say this is the machinery model we
use and this is what it shows us being
the most important features uh that
leads us to this predictions and
sometimes they will see that importance
and some features like oh that makes
sense or oh that doesn't that's
unexpected right and then
it goes off from there but if you're
using a little bit more solutions like
deep learning where things are a little
bit more black box um then that is where
if you had that communication with the
subject matter experts and they have a
slight idea of what your solution looks
like they can help a lot at that point
in terms of explaining that to their
colleagues and to their managers into
the decision makers so again it's a
two-way process in terms of success on
their side and on your side so that very
constant communication is what i found
is the key
thank you so much sylvia actually answer
my
question if there's no other questions
again uh thanks for coming to the
workshop i hope that um you find it
helpful in any sort of way um feel free
to stack me or go on the channel look
for the links to the notebook i also
have the link there to digital hub uh if
you're interested to learn a little bit
more there you can also contact us if
you want to see a demo what's your hub
or not uh and but yeah i would love to
hear from you guys and see what you
thought of the workshop
well thank you very much sylvia for
your time and your presentation it was
really interesting so thank you thank
you everyone and have a good time
thanks for coming